talk to us about coin clouds let's start
from the top in terms of just how many
employees how many locations how big is
the business from a financial standpoint
yeah so we're uh 240 employees we're
headquartered here in las vegas nevada
we've got 4 500 locations installed
today
uh in a variety of amazing retailers um
heb
711
many others uh you know we're bringing
this mainstream digital currency
mainstream so when you're at your
checkout counter look around you'll
probably see one of our kiosks
um
in terms of you know how big is this
financially yeah we're um
in the hundreds of millions if not
billions in terms of our total sales
today i
i'm not sure what we'll be at by the end
of this year um
we're looking forward to it to a good
november and december so i think we'll
we'll probably get into the billions
this year so got it and when you look at
uh how this works so you go to let's
take a 7-11 right or some other kind of
retailer you go to them and you get the
atm actually placed inside of that what
is the relationship between uh your
business and the retailer like i don't
think people understand how these
businesses work from like a mechanism
standpoint for us is really simple we're
subleasing basically a 1.6 square foot
space in their store
and the value proposition of them is
really simple they you know get rent so
based on the rent we pay we're already
the number one
you know revenue per square foot in
their entire store and you know if you
got a small c store or a grocery store
um they're really looking at that metric
in in addition to that rent and revenue
that we pay
we're bringing in
lots of new foot traffic so around 300
people a month are are coming to the
destination to buy and sell digital
currency
uh we're one of the few digital currency
machines that you know our entire
network is two-way and that you can buy
and sell and so you know that adds a lot
of repeat traffic
people who bought elsewhere want to cash
out
one of the only places they can get cash
for crypto is our kiosk and so that
drives a lot of traffic into their store
and retains a loyal customer and because
crypto is so sort of
new and scary to a lot of people
we have a live 24 7 customer support
line
that you know they can call anytime how
do i download a wallet how do i do my
first transaction how do i sell my
bitcoin for cash
where do i find a location where the
hours you know call us anytime well you
know you have to be a customer we'll
help you you know understand what
digital currencies are how to use them
and use our product and so
building that trust with our customer is
a really important piece of what we do
and uh brings a lot of customer loyalty
to both our business and the host
business got it and then walk me through
in terms of who is this for right i
think a lot of folks when they think of
buying bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
they're thinking about going on to uh
kind of a traditional exchange i'll put
traditional on air quotes of it's
something that i do on the internet i go
i sign up for an account and i go and i
purchase it that way these are in-person
physical retail uh devices so what is
the kind of um intended or target uh
demographic age um you know location
like how do you think about why somebody
would go to the physical uh system
rather than go online great question
that's just a lot of things uh
one key point most people understand
about our business but it's cash to
crypto there's no banking intermediary
uh with our product it's direct in and
out to crypto with with cash and you
know cash is in a very immediate payment
means and still serves 30 plus percent
of all transactional activity in the
united states you know kobe might have
put a dent into that a little bit but
cash isn't going anywhere
and there's a certain
piece of cash that is financially
independent from sort of the legacy
banking system that you don't need a
bank account
in order to
do these transactions and
as somebody who's been in crypto since
2010
uh i probably had
50 bank accounts closed because because
banks
saw you know a coinbase wire coming in
out of my account or gemini wire coming
out of my my account and for a long
period of time there was this sort of
you know embargo
um against people who did crypto
transactions and so
um
you know i think the importance of cash
to crypto
um is really
you know missed in the mainstream media
today
and uh you know we sort of provide that
sort of base level
of being able to supercharge your
dollars right you can you can take your
us dollar and you can turn it into a
digital currency and get
you know a million more use cases and
value out of it that's uh that's a
really powerful thing to
especially to people who are underbanked
that
or don't want to be banked or
are unbanked you know there's this whole
class of u.s citizens that um the
banking system just doesn't serve and
they still need to interact with the
global economy
and uh
you know cash to cryptos is an amazing
way for them to supercharge their
dollars